[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه حيث
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
ايران تنفذوا ثاني عمليه اعدام بحق متظاهر
منذ بدء الاحتجاجات الاخيره
اوروبا تبحث فرض عقوبات على روسيا وايران
بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
لندن تستبعدوا نجاح روسيا في السيطره على
دونيتك ولجان وزابريجيا
جديده حول الضغوط التي ادت لحظر حسابي
ترامب
احييكم
على ارتباط بحركه الاحتجاجات المتواصله في
البلاد منذ حوالي ثلاثه اشهر وذلك طبعا
موقع ميزان اون لاين افاد الموقع التابع
للسلطه القضائيه الايرانيه
في مدينه مشهد شمال شرق البلاد بعدما
اودينا بقتل عنصرين من القوى الامنيه
وفيما تستمر ردود الفعل الغاضبه على تنفيذ
عمليات الاعدام المرتبطه بالاحتجاجات خسرت
العمله الايرانيه المزيد من قيمتها امام
الدولار الامريكي
تظاهرات متواصلات تحيط بالنظام وتضرب
اقتصاد البلاد المنهالي في مقتل في خضم
عقوبات تلو اخرى
ليتراجع الريال الايراني المتعثر الى
مستوى منخفض جديد مقابل الدولار مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات والاضرابات العماليه
والاسواق وتزايد عزله البلاد وسط
الانتقادات الغربيه
للاجراءات الامنيه الصارمه التي يتخذها
النظام تجاه المحتجين حيث كان يتم بيع
الدولار بما يصل الى 300,000 ريال في ما
ارتفع بعد الاحتياجات الى اكثر من
370,000 ريال
وفقد الريال قرابه 14 في ال 100 عام من
قيمته منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات على مستوى
البلاد عقب مقتل مهس امين
قفزه كبيره انعكست هي الاخرى على ارتفاع
الاسعار مع عدم قدره النظام على دفع رواتب
المتقاعدين ما دفع بهم لتجمع في وقفات
احتجاجيه اضافه الى اضرابات في قطاعات
النفط والغاز والبذر كيماويات في
المحافظات الجنوبيه احتجاجا على الغلاء
والظروف المعيشيه الصعبه والتاخر في دفع
الرواتب
التحام التظاهرات بالاضطرابات ذلك ما
يخشاه النظام الايراني الامر الذي قد يؤدي
الى جل البلاد وحركتها الاقتصاديه المناكه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
اه ما في شيراز جنوبه ايران تداول ناشطون
مقاطع مصوره لاضلام النار في اعمده كاميرا
المراقبه
وعلى صعيد ردود الفعل الدوليه على
التطورات في ايران نيوزيلندا فرضت عقوبات
على 22 مسؤولا ايرانيا من بينهم قائد
الحرس الثوري وقائد الامن الداخلي ورئيس
شرطه الاخلاق ومنعتهم ايضا من دخول
الاراضي النيوزلنديا وذلك ردا على العنف
الممارسه على المحتاجين في ايران قالت
رئيسه وزراء نيوزلندا الى بلادها لا تزال
تقفوا الى جانب الشعب الايراني لا سيما
النساء والفتيات
ينضم الينا الباحث في الشان الايراني
وجدان عبد الرحمن اهلا بك سيد وجدان اذا
رغم الادانات ورغم الانتقادات ورغم
العقوبات على النظام الايراني الا انه
يستمر في اعدام المحتجين وكان وكان لا
رادعه لهذا النظام سيد وجدان
مرحله
المعرض التي او هي جزء من نظام الاصلاحين
الذين ارادوا ايضا ابقى هذا النظام ولا
ايضا حتى صوت الاسره بحيث انه همم المرشد
يقوم همم
[موسيقى]
بنت شقيقه
في السجون لذلك هذا النظام بلغ الى مرحله
هذا لا يريد ان يستمع الى همم هذه
المناشدات الداخليه والخارجيه همم لانه
يجد بانه بالفعل اصبح هنالك طلاق كامل ما
بين الشارع وما بين النظام لذلك طالع ما
هو الان يملك السلطه او يملك السلاح سانه
يستخدم القوه المفرطه ضننا
كيف يفهم المجتمع الدولي ذلك يعني اتخاذ
هذه الخطوه من قبل النظام كيف تفهم من قبل
المنظمات الدوليه
او استمرار هذا النظام بالاعداماته رساله
ايضا للمجتمع الدولي بانه القرارات التي
تتخذونها والعقوبات التي تفرضونها لا
نعتني بها وهذه قراراتكم بالنسبه لنا
مرفوضه ولا نجيب الى مطالباتكم في الداخل
ايضا رساله حتى المعارضه الداخليه او
للشارع الايراني الذي طالبه عدم الاعدامات
بانه هذه المناشدات لدينا قوه السلاح
المجتمع الدولي يفرث فقط عقوبات همم وهذه
العقوبات تتعود عليها النظام الايراني منذ
مده تاسيسه لذلك انه يحاول همم كما حاول
في المرات السابقه انه من خلال السلاح قمع
الشارع ولكن هذا ايضا لن يعالج الامر لم
يكن بالفعل النظام الايراني
ماذا عن 11
المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام الان في ايران
ماذا عنهم
على اعدام همم اليوم اعتقد انه هذا وارد
جدا انه بالفعل ان يخدم على هذا همم 11
همم معتدل هذا ايضا وارد جدا للاسف الشديد
المجتمع الدولي ومنظمات حقوق الانسان لم
تاخذ قرارات همم حاده اتجاه هذا النظام
الايراني لمنع هذا همم ارتكابات وهكذا
جرائم بحقل بحقل الانسانيه بين المفردات
الدول الاوروبيه بالفعل ان تقوم بردت فعل
النظام لايراني يستدعي سفرارها وهي فقط
يتفرج على ما يقوم به النظام
المشهد في ايران حتى الان انت وصفت بان
النظام دخل في مرحله الامتحانات
نتوقع مزيد من القمع لان الاحتجاجات ما
زالت مستمره الاعدامات لم توقف الشارع
شاهدنا انه في شارع ست ارقام حيث قتل
شكاري اعدمها شكاري شاهدنا نظام الايراني
في اليوم الاول ايضا قام باعتفالات
وشاهدنا ليله ايضا كانت ذلك احتجاجات
وتجمع كبير في شارع همم ستار خان الذي لا
يبعد عن بيت المرشد الى سبعه كيلو متر
ولهذا اعتقد اسرار الشارع وايضا اسرار
النظام كان يشهد هنالك المزيد من
الاغتيالات والمزيد من الاعدامات لكنها في
نهايه المطاف الشارع لن يعود وهذه
المطالبات مستمره لحين اصواته شكرا لك
البحث في شان الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن
كنت معنا من لندن
اطبخوا من اجل الايران مبادره جديده دعما
للاحتجاجات في ايران تعديل بعد نجاح
المبادرتين السابقين اطبخ من اجل سوريا
واطبخ من اجل الاوكرانيا المبادرات الثلاث
اطلقتها سيده الاعمال والناشطه الانسانيه
ليلى يرجاني وقد شارك فيها المئات من صناع
المحتوى على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بالاضافه الى نحو 30 شاف حول العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سواء داخل ايران او خارجها
[موسيقى]
حيوان
تاتي من عائله لها باع طويل في فن الطيب
اكتسبت من والديها وجديها ثقافه تقدر
اهميه الطعام في حفظ الذكريات تاريخ وطن
ابعدتهم الظروف عنه بعد نجاح مبادرتيها
هاشتاج اطبخ من اجل سوريا وهاشتاغ اطبخ من
اجل اوكرانيا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اراده الصدفه ان تحتاج ايران لمبادره
مماثله فلا احداث الاخيره جاءت فرصه لليله
للاضاءه على جانب مختلف من بلدها من خلال
مبادره هاشتاج اطبخ من اجل ايران
مهم جدا في تعزيز التعاطف وتطوير الارتباط
بالثقافه لانه شيء يستطيع الناس الاستمتاع
به كجزء من الثقافه والطعام الايراني
متنوع جدا من ناحيته التوابل والمكونات
واجد قادرا على اعطاء منظور مختلف عن
الشعب الايراني ولما يجري في ايران
شارك في حمله هاشتاج اطبخ من اجل ايران
حتى الان المئات من صناع المحتوى على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بالاضافه الى نحو
30 شفا محترفا من مختلف انحاء العالم من
بينهم عماد الارنب صاحب ومطبخ عماد السوري
في العاصمه لندن الذي يشارك فيها هاشتاق
اطبخ من اجل ايران من خلال طبق جولي معزا
هو عباره عن طبق سمينا الزهره مثلا لانه
هي ورده فجرت هي زهره فجلت ثوره اذا فيك
تقولي
ضوت ضوت على قضيه انسانيه
دوت على حقوق المراه يلي
احيانا بتكون مهمشه وهذا وهذا الشيء اللي
سويته عملته
وضلت وظلت كذلك
منذ ايام حياته في سوريا كما انه من رواد
المشاركين في مبادرات الانسانيه طوال
رحلتي لجوءه من سوريا حتى وصوله الى
بريطانيا
اعداد وجبه طعامك هذه ربما من افضل طرق
التضامن الثقافي في العالم فلا تاتوهاتي
مثل عماد ميزته خاصه وهي الاضاءه على
الجانب الاجمل لبلدان تركوها قصرا من خلال
اشتراك الناس في قضاياها السياسيه
والاجتماعيه من خلال فن الطبخ من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
فيما يخص الحرب في اوكرانيا مشاهدينا
استبعدت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تحقيق
القوات البريه الروسيه تقدمانيا كبيرا في
اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر القادمه
اليوم في محاوله من الاتفاق على فرد
المزيد من العقوبات على روسيا وعلى ايران
كذلك وتخصيص مليار يورو اضافيه لتزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه ومن المقرر ان يقرر
الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات اضافيه على
شخصيات وكينات ايرانيه بسبب طبعا تورطها
في انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان في ايران
والارتباطها بتزويد روسيا بطائرات مسيره
من بروكسل ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نور
الدين اهلا بك نور الدين حزمه تاسعه من
العقوبات على روسيا الان ما المتوقع
صباح الخير فاطمه
في عفوا في هذه اللحظات وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يجتمعون لاول مره معانا
وزراءهم ما يسمى به دول الشراكه الشرقيه
معنا اذربيجان ارمينيا
الدول التي تقع في حزام روسيا وهو اول
اجتماع منذ بدايه حرب اوكرانيا وما ملك
كفيف في هذه الحرب في عفوا في هذه
الاجتماع
الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب دول الشراكه
الشرقيه
بالالتزام بحزمه العقوبات التي يصدرها
الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد روسيا هذا من اجل
الضغط اكثر واكثر على الكاملا بالنسبه
للحزمه التاسعه من العقوبات التي ربما يتم
التوصل الى اتفاق حولها في مساء اليوم
ولكن في هذه اللحظه قبل حين قال جوزيف
بوريل ان الاجماع مفتقد حتى اللحظه صباح
اليوم بين الدول الاعضاء حول حزمه هذه
العقوبات مش يعني روسي يتفضل لماذا هناك
عدم اجماع نور الدين برايك هل من
المعلومات حول ذلك
المجر تعترض وتشكك في جدوى هاتي العقوبات
وتقول بان المزيد من العقوبات اضرت اكثر
بالاقتصاد الاوروبي باقتصادات الدول
الاوروبيه
واذا اخذت بشكل منفرد اكثر من ان تضر
بروسيا هذا هو الدليل والمبرر الاساسي
الذي تعتمده همم تعتمده همم المجر في
اعتراضيه على استمرار الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اصدار هذه سلسله من العقوبات ولكنها
مدعومه من حدث كبير خاصه بولندا والدول
البطيخ تفضلي طيب نور الدين ايضا ايران
لها نصيب من هذه العقوبات بسبب الاحتجاجات
وقم على احتجاجات وايضا لتزويدها مسيرات
لروسيا ماذا عن تفاصيل ذلك
ليس لها نصيب ايران لن يقولها نصيب فقط في
مجال العقبات وانما نصيب كبير جدا في
النقاشات التي سيجريها وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي بصفه معمقه لجوانب عده
في العلاقات المتوتره مع ايران وهاتي
نقاشات تتركز ظهرا اليوم بمتصفح يعني
منتصف النهار بتوقيتنا حول القمع المنهج
للسلطات الايرانيه ضد شعبها والاتحاد
الاوروبي يدعموا حق الشعب الايراني في
وتطلعاته الموسوعه نحو الحريه وتمثل
بالحقوق الاساسيه هذا مثل ما اا ورد في
النقاشات مع عدد من الدبلوماسيين النقطه
الثانيه تتعلق همم يعني موقف روسي او موقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي في ادانته ومطالبته
ايران بوقفه دعم روسي بالمسيرات والزامها
عدم تزويد روسيا بالتواريخ البالستيه
جوزيف قال بانه تحدث طويلا مساء الجمعه مع
امير عبد الله ابلغه هذا الموقف الاوروبي
تشدد سواء كان في ما يتعلق به وقف قمع
المظاهرات وخاصه عدم دعم روسيا وان حسب ما
قال جوزيه بريل امير عبد اللاهين وعده من
ان ايران لن تزود روسيا بالصواريخ والنقطه
الثالثه في هذا الاجتماع
المباحثات المعامله تتعلق بمستقبل الاتفاق
النووي وتمسك الاتحاد الاوروبي بهذه
الاتفاق
وعلى هامش او في غضونها سيتم الاتفاق حوله
حزمتين من العقوبات ضد ايران حزمه تتصل به
المسؤولين عن قمع الاحتجاجات وحزمه الاخرى
تتصل بالمسؤولين الايرانيين الذين يشرفون
على تزويد روسيا بدعم عسكريين في الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا
عن سابقه من المواقف الاوروبيه تجاه ايران
وروسيا
بالنسبه لايران فعلا الموقف الاوروبي يبدو
اكثر حزما وبالتالي اكثر فاكثر من اسبوع
الى اخر من اجتماعي لاخر يبدو الموت
الموقف الاوروبي متشددا اكثر في اكثر تجاه
ايران من خلال حزمات العقوبات المتتاليه
منذ شهر اكتوبر نوفمبر والان ويقول هاتي
النقاشات التي ستجر بشكل معمق ولكن لاول
مره منذ العام 2019 سيزر الاتحاد الاوروبي
بيانا شاملا حول العلاقات المتوتره مع
ايران هذا البيان همم في ست صفحات ونصف
الصفحه لم يشهد لم ينزل الاتحاد الاوروبي
بيانا بهذا الحجم وهذا طول النقاشات
العامه والفقرات في هذا البيان همم مفصله
جدا سواء كان يتعلق بحقوق الانسان سواء
كان بيتعلق بدعم ايران لروسيا ودعم ايران
لي وتسيير ايران وتزويد ايران لاطراف غير
حكوميه في في لبنان وفي كمان يعني بمعنى
حزب الله وهمم وكذلك الحوثيين بالمسيرات
هات النقاشات معمقه جدا نتوقعها ظهر اليوم
تفضلي شكرا لك نور الدين من بروكسل
حول ذلك ايضا وادي المزيد من النقاش ينضم
الينا المحلل السياسي ناصر زهير اهلا بك
سيد ناصر اذن يعني كلمه مفاوضات نسمعها
كثيرا في الفتره الاونه الاخيره ولكن في
المقابله الان الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول
مجموعات السابع يريدون ان يفرضوا المزيد
من العقوبات على روسيا لماذا هذا التناقض
هل الاولويه لانها الحرب او محاولات
التفاوض لاطاله اما هذه الحرب سيد ناصر
صباح الخير تحياتي لكم للمشاهدين يعني
الان بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي الاولويه
هي بالتاكيد انهاء الحرب والدفع نحو
مفاوضات هذا الموقف عبر عنه الرئيس
الفرنسي في اكثر من مناسبه والمستشر
الالماني وحتى عدد من القاده الاوروبيين
ولكن في الاطار الاخر ايضا الاوروبيين
مطرين بين قوسين لان يتمناه مع الولايات
المتحده في استمرار الضغط على روسيا بمعنى
ان الاوروبيين ليس لديهم اليه لمواجهه
روسيا لمواجهه روسيا في هذه الحرب سوى
بنقطتين النقطه الاولى هي ما يتعلق بارسال
الاسلحه ودعم اوكرانيا والنقطه الثانيه ما
تتعلق بالحقوبات العقوبات نتحدث الان عن
حزن من العقوبات ليست شديده كما كان متوقع
يعني عندما نتحدث عن تحديث السفر لاسعار
الغاز كما كان يطرح وكما كانت تطالب بعض
الدول في بولندا الى تحويل هذه العقوبات
لفرضها على شخصيات او كيانات فتعتبر هذه
العقوبات مخففه انه عن الماء ولكن هذه
سياسه توقفت لمده ثمانيه هي بالنسبه
للاوربيين
وبالان يعودون الاستمرار فيها ولكن بشكل
مخفف للغايه هي من وجهه نظر نوعا ما
اقتصاديه ومن وجهه نظر بعض الدول مثل
هنغاريا مثل الاسبانيه على سبيل المثال
التي عرضت تحديد سقف باسعار النفط تعتبر
خاطئه تعتبر مؤثر على الاوروبيين بشكل
اكبر مما تؤثر على روسيا كما ذكر مراسلكم
ولذلك هناك تحفظ كبير من بعض الدول او
القاده ولكن الاغلبيه تقوم بانه يجب
الاستمرار طيب في كلمته المصوره بالامس
سيده ناصر زنسكي تحدث ان هناك سيكون نتائج
مهمه متوقعه الاسبوع المقبل وكان ذلك
التصريح بعد ان اجرى محادثات مع امريكا
وتركيا وفرنسا الى ماذا يشير برايك
انا اعتقد بانه يشير الى امكانيه التفاوض
او الدخول في مفاوضات لانه البيت الابيض
قال بالامس بعد الاتصال بعيدنسكي بان
بايدين او البيت الابيض نوعا ما يشجع على
ان يكون هناك سلام وفق مبادئ الامم
المتحده يعني بمعنى انه يمكن ان يكون هناك
دفع في التفاوض ولكن من خلال التجارب
السابقه طوال الاشهر الماضيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه دائما المفاوضات تكون كما يسير
على حقل الالغام يعني بمعنى انه يمكن ان
تتوقع قبل بدائها ويمكن ان يكون هناك
عرقله كبيره ولكن في دعوه روسيا في اكثر
من مناسبه الى التفاوض دعوه الاوربيه ايضا
الى هذه المفاوضات الخارق الذي احدثه
مكنون عند زيارته الى واشنطن بان يكون
هناك تليين نوع ما هي الموقف الامريكي
نوعا ما يدفع الان الى امكانيه التفاوض او
امكانيه الدخول في هذه المفاوضات مع قرب
فصل الشتاء
والدفع نحو ايقاف لهذه الحرب ولكن وتصريح
بريطانيه يقول بان او من الاستخبارات
البريطانيه في الايام السابقه يقول بان
روسيا تدفع لايقاف الحرب من اجل تجميع
قواتها وشنه هجوم في الربيع يعني بمعنى ان
هناك فعليا ايرادا لوقف القتال في هذا
التوقيت
كما ذكرت سيدنا ناصر فقط لتجميع الاسلحه
على نتائج المفاوضات يعني بمعنى كيف ستكون
المفاوضات طوال هذه الاشهر الماضيه
بريطانيا تقول من اجل تجميع الاسلحه
والقوات
في كل الاحوال اذا فشلت المفاوضات ستعود
العمليات القتاليه بشكل في سوار ربيع او
الاشهر التي سيد ناصر
العقوبات والاستمرار في فرض المزيد من
العقوبات يعني كما ذكرت انت دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي تتماشى مع القرارات الامريكيه
الجميع متضرر روسيا والاوروبيين واوكرانيا
ولكن بشكل اكبر الحلقه 4 التي فيها الحرب
تتضرر ولكن بشكل قليل للغايه لانه الخسائر
التي تتكبلها الولايات المتحده داعي نقول
تعوضها فيما يتعلق في ارباح النفط والغاز
على سبيل المثال في ارتفاع الاسعار كما
تبيع الغاز الاوروبيين باربع اضعاف سعره
الذي تبيعه الى الداخل الاوروبي الان هم
الحلقه الاضعف ولكن روسيا ايضا ستت-
ستتضررها ولكن على المدى المتوسط والبعيد
الصين والهند هم العامل الذي وزن هذه
الحرب يعني بمعنى كل النفط والغاز الذي
توقف الاوروبيين عن شراء سوا كان بالعقبات
او توقفت روسي لان تشتريه كل من الصين
والهند باسعار تفاضليه وهذا ما عوض روسي
عن الحسائر فادحه كانت متوقعه في نتيجه
العقوبه شكرا لك المحلل السياسي ناصر زهير
صحيفه وصفيه قالت ان بعضا من اقوى الاسلحه
التي قدمها الغرب لاوكرانيا تختفي من ساحه
القتال لفتره طويله بسبب اجراء الصيانه
المعقده الامر الذي يشكل تحديا كبيرا امام
قوه كيب في التقدم نحو المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطره روسيا
تقدم الجيش الاوكراني في ساحه المعركه
يتباطئ ليس بسبب شده المواجهه بل لان
الاسلحه الغربيه المقدمه تحتاج صيانه
معقده بعيدا عن جبهه القتال
صحيفه
الثقيله هي الاكثر تضررا لتحتاج الى صيانه
متكرره بسبب استخدامها المكثف رغم انها
كانت حاسمه في الهجمات الناجحه الاخيره
لقوتك الصحيفه اكدت انه في بعض الحالات
يتطلب الامر صيانه الاسلحه على اراضي دول
حلف الناتو على بعد مئات الاميال من خط
المواجهه بسبب السريه المحيطه بهذه
الاسلحه وطابعها المعقد فاكرانيا لم تمنح
سوى عدد محدود من هذه الانظمه وغيابها عن
الجبهه اضافه الى عوامل اخرى كالطقس قد
يؤدي الى ابطائي تقدمه في الحرب وفقا
لمسؤولين في النار
فما دافعها وتزر مثلا تجب صيانتها خارج
اوكرانيا في 90 بالمئه من الحالات حسب
ضباط اوكرانيين خبراء وقالوا ان
الاوكرانيين لديهم نظام صيانه مكون من
ثلاثه مستويات في القوه الاوكرانيه
المدربه في الخارج تحاول اصلاح الاسلحه في
هذا النظام قبل التحدث الى الخبراء
الغربيين اذا لزم الامر لتلقي الارشادات
عبر الهاتف او الانترنت
ففي معظم الحالات تتطلب الاسلحه صيانه
واصلاحات دوريه بسبب الاستخدام المكثف لها
الامر الذي يجعل تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه
بطيئا خاصه في ظل المناخ الشتوي الصعب
بلال الوجداني العربيه
اكدت الخارجيه الروسيه انها تسعى لادخال
تغييرات في اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب لضمان
وصول المواد الغذائيه الى الدول الاشد
فقرا واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه انها ترى ان
اسطنبول مكان مناسب للمباحثات مع واشنطن
لكنها لا ترى اي نهج بناء من الولايات
المتحده من اجل اجراء هذه المباحثات
نشرتنا تستمر ولكن بعد الفاصل مجلس الامن
القومي الليبي يعبر عن استغرابه لمحاكمه
ابو عجيله على خلفيه هجوم لوكربي
الاخبار ولا تتوقف ابدا الناس تحصل عليها
من عده مصادر
من وسائل مختلفه طوال الوقت
[موسيقى]
ويستدعي ان نصلي الضوء عليه المناقشه
نضعه في عدسه واحده
لابعد الحدود
[موسيقى]
الثامنه على شاشه العربيه
على الارض
ولكن ما يجعلك مختلفا حقيقه هو قدرتك على
الرؤيه من زوايا متعدده لتغطي الحدث من
جميع الجوانب الافضل هو قيامك بتجزئه
الملفات والربط بين عناصرها مع الاستعانه
بالخبراء والمحللين
لجعل الاخبار اكثر فهما العربيه 360 من
الاحد الى الخميس العاشره على شاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد شركه تويتر مشاهدينا
تواصلوا برئاسه الماس كشف تفاصيل سريه حول
الطريقه التي تعاملت بها الشركه مع حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق والضغوط التي ادت
الى حضر حساب نهائيا وبحسب الدفع الجديده
من ملفات تويتر السريه تم حظر الرئيس
السابق من تويتر بعد يوم من مطالبه السيده
الاولى السابقه ميشيل اوباما واخرين
الشركه بازالته نهائيا ثم الكشف عن ذلك
الدفعه الرابعه من وثائق تويتر التي تظهر
الاتصالات الداخليه من قبل المديرين
التنفيذيين للشركه بين السادس والثامن من
يناير 20 واحد و20 من بيروت ينضم الينا
الدكتور باول المرقص استاذ القانون الدولي
ورئيس منظمه جوستا الحقوقيه اهلا بك معنا
دكتور اذا اسماء كثيره غير متوقعه تظهر
على الساحه بعد تسريبات ملفات تويتر الى
ماذا يسعى الى الماسك
يسعى ان يكون رقما صعبا تعرفين انه منذ
تواليه ملكيه هذه المنصه العريقه فقط اراد
من وراءها ان يعني يضع جدول اعمال
مليء بالبنود الساخنه منها المساله
الماليه وخفض التكاليف وصرف عاملين واعاده
فتح حسابات مغلقه كما تفضلتم وابرزها
للرئيس الامريكي ترامب ملف همم يعني بايضا
الابن همم
ملفات اخرى ايضا تتعلق بالوثائق التي بدات
تسريبها وبالتالي يريد من وراء ذلك ان
يؤكد على امرين اولا عدم المساس بمكانته
وبموته
بوعيه المؤسسه التي هو على راسها بعد ما
لاحت في الافق بعض
افكار المتعلقه بضبط هذه الحركه
المستجده من حيث تضييق عليه ووضع قيود
واجراء تعديلات على القانون تعريفين انه
ثمه سنوات لغايه اليوم هنالك على بساط
البحث تعديل قانوني في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لتضييق الخناق على هكذا منصات
هو ثانيا يريد ان يؤكد على حريه التعبير
بالمطلق وفق التعديل الامريكي للدستور
التعديل الاول الذي يضمن حريه التعبير
ولا يجيز التدخل كيف يمكن له ان يؤثر على
اساس الامريكيين وعلى الديمقراطيه بشكل
عام
هو طبعا يؤثر على الشاشه بمجرد انه يحوز
معلومات
لكي نقول سريه على الاقل مميزه معلومات
فريده معلومات خاصه
بهؤلاء او باقرباء لهم او بعاملين معهم من
المستشارين وسواهم كانوا يتواصلون مع
مديرين في التويتر وبالتالي فان التهويل
والتلميح بامكانيه الكشف عن هذه المراسلات
هو امر مهم جدا يجعل منه صاحب اا اذا اردت
يعني حصانه ذاتيه لا يمكن الاقتراب منها
بسهوله كما تمت اشاعته في الايام
والاسابيع القليله الماضيه من امكانيه
التضييق عليه وعلى المنصه ووضع قيود
وضوابط جديده لكن القانون الامريكي
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يذهبوا المسؤولون
الامريكيون لرضع الى الماسك
هو لا لا يخشى بالتمام خشيه شخصيه انما هو
قد اثار زوبعه من ال يعني الاحاديث عندما
تسلم مقاليد رئاسه تويتر مؤخرا ومن ذلك
قيل انه يراد ايضا تنظيم هذا القطاع على
نحو يجعله غير متفرد وخاضع لضوابط اا يعني
بين الى اين هي ضوابط حكوميه بينما يتمسك
هو بان التعديل الدستوري الامريكي الاول
يعطيه حريه وحصانه تقيح من هذه الضوابط
والقيود وهو اليوم يلمح ويلوح بهذه
المعلومات السريه الخاصه المميزه التي
يريد ان يفشيها على دفعات حتى يقول انه
يمتلك مخزونا كبيرا من المعلومات المتصله
بالساسه الامريكيه
بالمحيطين بهم بحيث يرضع هذه الامكانيه
التهديد
يعني التضييق عليه وعلى منصبته كيف يمكن
ان تؤثر على حظوظ
الحزب الديمقراطي في الانتخابات القادمه
في 20 24
الامر متعلق تحديدا
بمضمون هذه المراسلات التي لم تكشف كلها
بعد
انما بطبيعه الحال هنالك خشيه لدى اوساط
الحزب الديمقراطي وتقرئين يعني في الصحف
همم اليوم البارحه هذا القلق ال- ال-
المستمر انما همم ربما تكون يعني همم قمه
او ذروه هذا القلق اذا اصطدم اكثر فاكثر
همم مؤسس او همم صاحب ملكه تويتر باهانتر
بايدن الذي هو ابن الرئيس الامريكي
لوح انه قام بها هذا يؤثر طبعا على الحدود
بشكل عام طيب شكرا لك من بيروت الدكتور
فاول المرقص استاذ القانون الدولي ورئيس
منظمه الحقوقيه
واصل واصدار اعلاناته وجديدها حسب وصفه
ميزه تشرح سبب حجم حسابات بعض المستخدمين
من دون علمهم وكيفيه التعامل معها
من معرفه ما اذا كانت حساباتهم تتعرضوا
للحجم والاخفاء دون علمهم وايضا كيفيه
التعامل مع هكذا موقف
هذا ما اعلن عنه رئيس شركه تويتر
الملياردير الامريكي
تشرح سبب حجب حساباتي بعض المستخدمين
صعوبه العثور على صفحه الشخص في خانه
البحث منشورات المستخدم غير مرئيه لمستخدم
تويتر والمتابعين هذا الاعلان وان كان ليس
غريبا على الى الماسك المثير للجدل الا
انه اثار سجالات وعزائه البعض الى الجدل
الذي احاطته وتر في عقاب تقرير حديث اصدره
موقعه
المتخصصه في امن المعلومات قال فيه ان
تويتر يمكنه الوصول الى بيانات مستخدم
اكثر من 40 الف موقع الكتروني التقرير
اشار الى ان من بين هذه المواقع التي
يستطيع تويتر الحصول على بيانات مستخدميها
مواقع تابعه للحكومه الامريكيه واخرى
لشركات الرعايه الصحيه حيث بامكان تويتر
الحصول على البيانات عبر اداه الاعلان
الخاصه به التي تسمى بكسل والتي يضمنها
المعلنون في مواقعهم لتتبع وتحليل
واستهداف المستخدمين منصه تويتر تستعد
ايضا بدءا من الثانيه عشر من ديسمبر
لزياده اسعار الاشتراك لخدمتها المدفوعه
تويتر بلو على تطبيق اجهزه ابل ما يعني
تحميل المستخدم تكلفه الحصه التي تقطعها
ابل من المدفوعات بسعر 11$ في حين سيتم
تخفيض السعر الى ثمانيه دولارات اذا تم
الاشتراك بها عبر موقع الويب ابل ستور
ريماس في اصدار اعلاناته الا انه لم ينسى
التهديد بمقادتي عدد قليل من موظفي تويتر
الذين يواصلون تسريب معلومات سريه لوسائل
الاعلام وفق تقارير جاسم محسن العربيه
في امريكا على خلفيه هجوم لكربي وقال مجلس
الامن القومي الليبي ان واشنطن تعاهدت عام
2008 بانهائي اي مطالبات مرتبطه بهجوم
لوكربي وكان ابو عجاله مسؤولا في جهاز
المخابرات عهد النظام الليبي السابق وتمت
ادانته بتهم لها علاقه بالحادث المميت
الذي لاحظ حياته 270 شخصا من بينهم 190
امريكيا وذلك خلال رحله طيران بين لندن
ونيويورك
تحضري ايام ما توصلت معنا مجموعه وقالوا
لنا ان هو موجود عندنا كانت اللي هي
المشتركه في مدينه مصراته
وفعلا تمكنك ابنه
وبنته وزوجته من ديارتها وشفوه طبعا الرجل
كان مريض النووي عنده مشاكل صحيه وفي
اليوم اللي اختطفوا فيه هذا
لثلاث ايام مرتبه يعني واخذ دور برد
الايام وفي طبعا
وجماعه طمنونا وقالوا انه هو موجود عندنا
يعني احنا وكده اليوم
على مواقع
الولايات المتحده الاخبار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
متابعوا بعض الفاصل
الجيش الباكستاني يعلن مقتل سته مدنيين في
قصف النفذته قوات الحدود الافغانيه
اوروبا تبحث فرض عقوبات على روسيا وايران
بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
ماسك يكشف وتفاصيل جديده حول الضغوط التي
ادت لحظر حساب ترامب
احييكم من جديد اعلن الجيش الباكستاني
مقتل سته مدنيين واصابه 17 اخرين خلال قصف
نفذته قوات الحدود الافغانيه وذلك
بالاسلحه الثقيله وقبائل في الهون ضد
السكان المدنيين في قريه شامان على المعبر
الحدودي الذي يستخدم للتجاره والعبور
ويربط ايضا ولايه بلوشستان غرب باكستان مع
قندهار جنوب افغانستان في مقاله الشرطه
الافغانيه ان جنديا قتل خلال اشتباكات مع
القوات الباكستانيه وجرح 10 اخرون
مراسل العربيه مشاهدينا قال ان طفله قتلت
برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه وذلك خلال
الاقتحامها للحي الشرقي في مدينه جنين في
الضفه الغربيه فيما اصيب ثلاثه فلسطينيين
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في بيان انه انسحب
من المدينه بعد اعتقال شابين كان يخططان
لتنفيذ هجوم في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
من كبار المسؤولين الصينيين وقال المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان هذه العقوبات
الحقوق ضررارا خطيرا بالعلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه من جهه اخرى
وزير الخارجيه الصيني خلال اليومين الماضي
في مدينه القريبه من بكين من دون ذكر
نتائج هذا الاجتماع
ننتقل الان مباشره الى الاقتصاد
شكرا لك فاطمه اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا
نتابع حركه سوق الاسهم السعوديه المؤشر
يواصل انخفاضاته على مدار الاسابيع
الماضيه حاليا منخفض بواحد ونصف النقطه
المئويه كسرنا عتبه العشره الاف نقطه
نزولا هذا توضيح اذا مشاهدينا لحركه السوق
منذ اخر مره كانت السوق اغلقت فوق ال
12000 نقطه في نهايه شهر اكتوبر
التراجعات منذ ذلك الوقت من فوق 12,000
نقطه نتراجع بحوالي 17% كسرنا مستوى
12,000 11,000 واليوم كسرنا مستويات
10,000 هذه اول مره المؤشر يتداول دون
عتبه ال 10,000 نقطه منذ مارس من العام 20
21 همم طبعا الانخفاضات التي نشهدها في
السوق تزامنت في نفس الفتره مع التراجعات
التي شهدتها اسعار النفط في نفس الفتره
الزمنيه منذ نهايه شهر اكتوبر تقريبا في
فوق العشرين من اكتوبر الماضي تراجعات
براند ب 19 في المئه ونلحق طبعا هذا
الترابط العلاقه همم الكوريليشن القوي في
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه ما بين همم اسعار
خام برنت وحركه مؤشر سوق الاسهم السعوديه
هذه نظره اذا الان على سهم امريكانا
للمطاعم التي ادرجت اليوم لاول مره
بالتزامن بين السعوديه والامارات في بورصه
ابو ظبي السهم على ارتفاع بواحد في المئه
الى ريالين و73 هل لها سعر الاكتتاب
والطرح كان عند الريالين و 68
هلال اذا المكاسب اقل من اثنين في المئه
همم فقط ماذا عن الاسهم الاكثر نشاطا في
هذه اللحظات امريكانا للمطاعم والسهم
الاكثر نشاطا لكن لاحظ مشاهدينا الراجحي
البنوك تحت الضغط هذا سهم الراجحي متراجع
باثنين ونصف نقطه المئويه الى 72 ريال
ونصف الريال همم طبعا معظم الاسهم
المصرفيه على انخفاض نلقي نظره على البنوك
لاحظوا على بنك الرياض باكثر من اربعه%
الراجحي ب 2.5 النقطه المئويه سهم الفرنسي
ايضا تراجعات بنحو اثنين في المائه طبعا
هذا اسبوع سيكون حافل باجتماعات البنوك
المركزيه عالميا وكل اعين ستنصب على قرار
اجتماع الفدرالي يوميه الثلاثاء والاربعاء
من المتوقع ان يقوم برفع نسبه الفائده ب
50 نقطه اساس بعد ان كان رفعها في اخر
اربع مرات بواقع 75 نقطه اساس في كل همم
مره وبالتالي هذا بطبيعه الحال سيؤثر على
حركه اسواق الاسهم همم وشهيه المخاطره
عالميا بما فيها همم اسواقنا المحليه هذه
اذا كانت مشاهدينا وقفه مع تداولات السوق
الاسهم السعوديه نعود الان من جديد الى
استديوهاتنا في الرياض واليك فاطمه شكرا
ناصر
والى اخبار المونديال اصدرها لاعب كره
القدم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو بيانا
عبر حساباته في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اكد فيها انه حارب من اجل حلم كاس العالم
وان هناك الكثير قد قيل وكتب ولكن
الالتزامه للبرتغال لم يتغير ولو للحظه
وانه لم يدير ظهره لزملائه او لبلده على
حد تعبير اللاعب البرتغالي
هو من تجوز عتبه الثلاثين وزاد عليها
اعوام سبعه اللاعب الملقب بصاروخ مديره
يقترب من نهايه مسيرته الكرويه كريستيانو
رونالدو يلوح مودع مونديال قطر بالدموع
ومسجلا رقما سلبيا في مسيرته لم يحدث
على التوالي في بطوله الكبرى واخفاقه في
تسجيل الاهداف مع البرتغال خلال الادوار
الاقصائيه في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
دقيقه وتسديده 27 مره
بحجم كريستيانو رونالدو الهداف التاريخي
لمنتخب البرتغال باهدافه المئه وثمانيه
عشر
ومتساويا بمبارياته التي وصل عددها
296 مع الكويتي بدر المطوع في صداره اكثر
لا العالم خوضا للمباريات الدوليه على مر
التاريخ
ومن كان صوره لمنتخب بلاده قرابه عقدين من
الزمن تولى قياده البرتغال في يوليو 2008
وفاز معه ببطوله امم اوروبا 2016
حاصل على الحذاء الذهبي كافضل هداف في
بطوله امم اوروبا
على المنتخب في مونديال 2022
امام غانا سجل رونالدو ركله جزائر واصبح
اول لاعب يسجل في خمس بطولات مختلفه
لكنه وضع بعدها على دكه البدلاء امام
سويسرا والمغرب
افضل لاعب في العالم خمس مرات يمر بازمه
حاليا برحيله عن مانشستر يونايتد بعد فسخ
عقده مع اداره النادي الانجليزي
يشارك في دوري ابطال اوروبا ولكن ربما
يواجه صعوبه في تحقيق مبتغاه بعد
انتقاداته السابقه لاداره يونايتد في
مقابله تلفزيونيه ومردوده الفني في
المنتخب العربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد فوزه اسود الاطلس على البرتغال بهدف
من دون رد في كاس العالم 20 22 في قطر
حققه منتخب المغرب مجموعه من الارقام
القياسيه رفقت انجازه تاريخي بالوصول الى
نصف نهائي كاس العالم نستعرض هنا قائمه
بابرز الارقام القياسيه التي حققها منتخب
المغرب بفضل مشواره المميز في المونديال
حتى الان
والى المزيد من الاخبار الرياضيه في
التقرير التالي نتابع
الارجنتين خدمات المدافع الاساسيه
حول مشاركه النجم ديماريا بسبب الاصابه
واشاهد التشكيله كرواتيا عوده المدافع
بورناسوسه قبل مواجهه الارجنتين بعد غيابه
عن مباراه البرازيل
وجهها كريم بنزيما مهاجم ريال مدريد رساله
دعم لرفاقه في المنتخب الفرنسي عقبه تاهله
لنصف نهائي كاس العالم عبر حساباته على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تحدث نجم منتخب المغرب والنصر السابق نور
الدين مرابط عن المدرب رونار ومشاركه
المنتخب السعودي في المونديال
المدرب رونالدو قام رائع كان لديهم روح
ومستوى تكتيكي عالندا للاسف كانوا غير
محظوظين لكن لديهم مستقبل كبير ينتظرهم
الفرنسيه على ليفربول الانجليزيه بثلاثه
اهداف مقابل هدف واحد ضمن بطوله كاس
السوبر دبي الوديه
وفاز استون فيلا الانجليزيه على مواطنه
تشيلسي بهدف منذ نرد في لقاء نور الدين
اقيم في العاصمه الاماراتيه ابوظبي
مع استمرار التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه في
البلاد بسبب ازمه السياسيه الاخيره حيث
تجمع الالاف للمطالبه باستقاله الرئيس
الجديده دينا بول ورت وتحديد موعد
للانتخابات العامه واعلان حريه الرئيس
هيدرو كاستيلو الذي عزله المشروعون
الاربعاء الماضي فيما استخدمت الشرطه
المتظاهرين والغاز المسير للدموع
قصر بيكنج همام نشر صوره لبطاقه عيد
الميلاد الاولى للملك تشارلز وهي صوره
التقطت له والد زوجته كامله في الثالث من
سبتمبر الماضي عندما كان وليا للعهد
والتقطت الصوره خلال حضورهما دوره العاب
برايمر في سكوتلندا للالعاب والرياضه
والرقص الاسكتلنديه التقليدي في قريتين
تبعد 60 ميلا غربي مدينه قرب قصر بلمونال
الصيفي مطار هيثرو اكثر المطارات ازدحاما
الغى اكثر من 50 رحله جويه اليوم وذلك
بسبب الطقس الشتوي الذي ادى الى اضطراب في
جميع انحاء البلاد ياتي ذلك في الوقت الذي
اصدر فيه مكتب الارصاد الجويه عده تحضيرات
من الضباب والثلج والجليد في اجزاء من
البلاد
[موسيقى]
في الختام دوما ان نذكر بالعناوين
ايران تنفذوا ثاني عمليه اعدام بحق متظاهر
منذ بدء الاحتجاجات الاخيره
اوروبا تبحث فرض عقوبات على روسيا وايران
وبسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
روسيا في السيطره على دونيه
جديده حول الضغوط التي ادت لحظر حساب
ترامب
نهايه النشره في امان الله
[موسيقى]